[Music]
welcome home and have heard about the
circumstances surrounding the death of
Detective long no that looks like the
green arrow was manipulated into killing
it's time I faced this at all
[Music]
finally it's about time someone figured
it out
[Music]
hey youtubers is charlie new arrow
footage confirming which version of
laurels coming back so let's break it
down and there is a new brand of the
flash ring giveaway going on now all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be
sure to click that Bell to enable alerts
so you don't miss anything during the
break so let's just say what we're all
thinking the simplest explanation is
usually the right one so this is
probably black siren but who knows why
she's here what does she want from Team
arrow because most of the time the
metahumans attack STAR Labs because
they're looking for technology or they
want to fight the flash they just come
from the flash TV show so they tend to
be flash problems now when it involves
arrow it might still have something to
do with something she's trying to get
like maybe something that Felicity is
designing or mr. terrific is designing
or less likely but I would really be
excited if it has something to do with
the Prometheus plot now I'm gonna give
them the benefit of the doubt and say
team flash probably told team arrow
about earth to Laurel black siren in the
adventure that they had fighting her why
is it always so difficult to choose
Laurel Lance
with a single call you can take down a
building I'd call that impressive but
why stop there
why serve a master when you can be a
master when you can be a god
we could be thought
like look there's this evil version of
Laurel that we captured we sent her back
to earth-2 but now for some reason she's
messing with team arrow like she just
shows up in the arrow cave which makes
you wonder how she knows where it is
is she working with Prometheus where did
she get that information what is her
relationship with the earth to green
arrow or the hood Robert Queen I'm not
expecting him to pop up but what might
be happening here is that she was stuck
on earth 1 and she never went back to
earth 2 she just escaped the pipeline
prison because of flashpoint in now team
arrow has something that she wants or
just like she was working with zoom
she's working with someone else and
obviously because it's arrow the big bad
on arrow this season is prometheus
there's just a number of different
possibilities so you guys can let me
know who is she working with and what is
it that she wants does she just want to
kill team arrow torment them like
Prometheus is trying to torment them or
does she actually want something so it
really just depends on how important you
think that she's going to be to the
overarching story of this season but
here's what I think is going on she'll
just come back on the show every once in
a while as flashback Laurel as black
siren but she's not a series regular so
I'm not expecting her to be in every
single episode but there's always the
potential for a future season for her to
come back for an extended arc where
she's not so evil and she's like
comic-book Black Canary fighting with
the green arrow but it seems like for
you know whatever her arc is gonna be in
the back half of the season she's still
gonna be pretty evil this time so it'll
be a lot of fun I'm happy that she's
back I'm really happy that it's black
siren I mean it's just one of the
easiest ways for them to do metahuman
Black Canary stuff without actually
having the Black Canary around so
another big question do you think she'll
actually wind up wearing laurels costume
that'd be pretty crazy
I did like the super goth doubt costume
that she wore on the flash that was a
lot of fun so we'll just see what
happens with that the other part of this
is Adrian chase helping out Diggle and
it looks like Diggle takes a swing at
him here in this interrogation room like
he's probably just trying to get him
riled up but I love the idea that Adrian
chase talking to Oliver has an idea that
the green arrow was manipulated into
killing Billy and now that he's helping
Diggle he just
provoking it so there's just a couple
different stories here that he's gonna
be a really big part of as vigilante and
then ask Adrian chase so big character
in the back half in addition to
prometheus two different characters just
to be clear prometheus is a different
character from the vigilante this city
is out of control and you haven't been
able to save it take one more step and
one of you isn't going home tonight if
you're not with me then you're against
me then I'm against you then you're a
dead man
did we scared him off he'll be back
and I know there's still a lot of people
that have a lot of questions about
Prometheus's identity but the whole idea
is that he is the son of someone that
Oliver killed in a princess bride style
he's exacting his revenge you killed my
father prepare to die family children to
death nobody cares about those people
they're a blight I'm just finding the
herd so worried
did you hesitate at all when you killed
him or was he just another name you
crossed off your list
if you want revenge I'm right here this
is about so much more than revenge so
they haven't said anything about more
crossovers with the flash in the back
half of the season but they do have like
the flash Super Girl crossover it's
supposed to be a musical episode that's
completely separate from what's going on
on arrow they're not gonna do an arrow
musical episode mostly because Stephen
Amell vetoed it but also because it
doesn't really fit with the tone of
arrow so I'm totally cool with that but
they usually do a minor crossover in the
back half of the season so they'll
probably will be another flash crossover
where they get some help with technology
or some help with their Prometheus
problem but they haven't really said a
lot about that yet and the other big
thing that we do not see in this trailer
is Oliver trying to track down the woman
that trained both him in prometheus back
in Russia who is probably Talia al Ghul
he said in that other trailer which I'll
post a link to at the end of this that
she doesn't stay in one place she moves
around so we'll probably flashback to
him actually meeting her and then in
present-day it will probably just take
him a while to track her down but it
seems great so far I love the direction
the arrows going I love some of the
stuff that it's doing there's still a
couple of storylines that they've teased
that we don't know anything about yet
they said that Felicity is gonna go
super dark she's gonna reconnect with
the hacker community that she was
connected to when she was in college so
it'll have something to do with the
smoke technology storyline that will
probably end up playing out during
season six next year but a lot of what
it seems like they're doing over the
course of arrow this season is returning
it to base comic book Green Arrow where
Oliver Queen isn't really questioning
who he is he knows who he is he's the
Green Arrow he knows what he wants to do
and he's doing Green Arrow type things
rather than sitting around moping being
sorry for himself just you know
superhero social justice warrior just
kicking the [ __ ] out of people but it's
gonna be a while before we find out
what's gonna be happening in season 6
like we really need to see how the
Prometheus plot plays out what they do
with black siren
in the future what's gonna be happening
with the mayor Oliver Queen's storyline
I don't think that's gonna stick first
you know some reason he's gonna have to
step down eventually it'll probably have
something to do with the Prometheus plot
so he'll be mayor but not forever just
like in the comics like it didn't stick
for forever but if you haven't been
watching arrow week to week be sure to
start doing that now it's actually
pretty good now so it's a lot more fun
than it's been in previous seasons but
what's gonna happen later tonight just
because I've been posting so many DC
videos is I'll post a Marvel video and
then I'll be posting Superman vs
Deathstroke then I'll post some more
flash season 3 so there's a whole bunch
of comic-book stuff happening this week
the break is only a couple weeks away
from being over it's like less than four
weeks before all the shows come back so
I'll just remind everyone what the
schedule is when I post DC videos well
you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for like the crazy Superman
lives
Supergirl lives Trail it's the Nicolas
Cage version of Superman and you can
click here for that other arrow trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight